live didn't do a morning session
today I wanted to get my uh my run in
before it would be too hot and then I
had to go do some server maintenance so
we're getting a little bit of a late
start but we do have a working server
that we can use to run some experiments
uh so that's nice that required a full
CPU swap and a OS
reinstall we have the whole process of
uh new OS install to having puffer
working down to like 10 minutes though
it's pretty nice clean box to working
puffer it's like 10
minutes okay so we have a lot of stuff
to do today lot a lot of stuff to do
today
um anything here
again which box yeah linky we now have a
puer box zero up that you can add to the
bot I didn't see this on the bot
otherwise I would have uh
oh literally right as soon as I go and
get on to stream this thing is uh go
seven is
down I got to ask that guy if he wants
me to reinstall the box with the buntu
to see if that's more stable cuz I've
been having uh better luck I think with
five now that we've got a buntu on
it
okay thank
you so there's going to be some work to
do today on this on this and other
things
um main thing I really want to do is I
want to have this for parameter sweep
just running itself in the background
without me having to do too too
much so I ran these
experiments and I would like to know why
this pushes down to minimum
auntu I can do that no I think puff
login is already on a b 2 Link it's it's
just on an older version but puff login
should already be on a bun
remember yeah you're free to play with
that box
though I if the power goes out the power
goes out so it's not going to do
anything
but new facility
is uh do I have this message hang on let
me see if I can find
this okay I have a picture somewhere of
the electrical wiring that looks pretty
cool for the new warehouse but I don't
see it
here probably my email or
something so here's what I want to
know um this can be made substantially
higher this score over
here it doesn't seem enticed to push out
to higher cost though log yeah that's
fine eventually the thing is we're going
to get these systems so stable we're not
going to need a ton of logging but yeah
it's we have to get there
obviously I think the uh the container
changes will help 80% uh dis and you
know 90%
Ram yeah see this cost is so weird let's
look at all the
parameters so I mean batch size this is
pretty reasonable right it's got some
here it's got some here this is
reasonable time steps is the one that
goes all the way down okay that's cost
related learn running
rate we kind of need multiple graphs for
this don't
we here we'll do
this we're going to be uh we become
stock Trader look alike for the day with
all these
graphs all right so we'll do this and
then this one will be
sample
so we get learning rate which is O2
looks to be around the
best uh there are a lot of runs at this
learning
rate that's probably the
resample and then what do we have this
learning rate O2 is the center yeah this
is pretty good I mean this is about what
we would want and then gamma do we have
a
gamma o 0.9
interesting we have a lot of gamas here
though that's very
weird but yeah look at all these minimum
gamma rules at the bottom that's
I mean I guess it it gets like a lucky
one and then
it
interesting maximum gradient
M
yeah BF coefficient here 0.8 yeah this
is fine it's a little spread but it's
fine
yeah and the gradient Norm gets up to
1.6 which is here yeah this pushes too
high I don't know why it would push this
high
time it got this point relatively early
on
is it just like a lucky Point not
resampling is this the
problem so what about call
cost I think we're using log cost the
distance at the moment
interesting like it doesn't want to put
any points out farther
uh if we compare this to the other runs
that we have so far so we've got 53 runs
okay so it's not finding anything
better
H is not finding anything better
also I don't know if we
do in what space we do the log cost as
well I'm to look at the algorithm a bit
and see if we can figure out where these
uh these issues are coming
from well welcome YouTube folks this is
currently analysis and tweaks
on uh the new hyperparameter tuning
algorithm that we are working on which
it looks like it's going to be a very
strong soda algorithm but there are
there just a few quirks with it mainly
about how it handles uh which it needs
to handle selecting an experiment based
on its cost better it tends to run too
many short experiments at the moment
it's a fine balance cuz sometimes it's
like too many long experiments too many
short experiments just need some
tweaks
okay puffer
here and I want to see how we're doing
the cost of the
m so we use nearest Paro distance this
is the term that tells us where on the
xaxis we should try to
sample and we use Paro log C
Norm which is you take the
cost you log it and then you Norm
it that's correct
right log cost and then it gets normal
okay
so it goes 0 to one on a log
scale and it's based
on what's this yeah the current mins and
Max
cost I mean so if you have something at
200 and you have something 400 right
it's going to go0
1 oops I'm covering this with my head so
this is zero and then if you have a
point here this would become
scaled that does incentivize you to
explore low
cost huh it's ironic because I think I
did this for the opposite reason right
if I do
here I think in my mind the way that I
was thinking about it is
that you probably want your runs to be
logarithmically spaced
out over
time um but this is making it way too
conservative yeah so I was basically
does that thing even that I was thinking
make any
sense I don't know if it does because I
think that what will happen with this
log spacing the way I have it is it'll
get like all point at 800 all point at
four uh all point at 800 two points
around like 400 so in this region then
Four Points here and like you get a
whole cluster from at the bottom
Baseline I mean this works super cleanly
on the synthetic tasks though right
so before I go messing with
this why does this
oh hangang
on there's something I missed here
right so if you don't have a parito
point to the left of
you yeah okay so if you do not have a
parito point to the left of you you get
the
entire you're rewarded this uh this much
where is it GP PT YT nor minus nearest
Paro
YT so nearest Paro
left this is the difference between the
cost and the Paro costs
right and we'll move this as well so
it's not covering
chat difference between cost and Pito
cost and
then any point the Pito it's going to be
more expensive get uh get masked
out but then if everything is infinite
then you end up with just a random
point which would then make this thing
negative I would think
which isn't what we want but should have
the opposite effect as what we're
observing right
now do we see this is this environment
specific or do we get this on pong as
well let me
see we have these pong runs
right okay now we do get this on pong as
well look this is
pong the thing is it's not as bad on
because like this is kind of where you
want to explore anyways like these
points out here probably have gotten a
little bit more attention but um me
you're kind of have you kind of have the
M solve by over here
anyways think was this one 12
20.8 yeah one of these two points is
going to be optimal
already and then this massive cluster
down here is just ridiculous
this yeah I really shouldn't be getting
very much for this um Improvement the
way that it works the improvements to
the score close to the top end are way
more heavily weighted than improvements
towards the bottom end so it really
should not be getting much reward for
anything that's down here
but apparently it is and now we see this
on two different environments so that's
a
trend
um just see here a minute and think
about
I'm just take my supplements now um and
then we're going to think through
this so much work to get one of these
algorithms really really working
correctly but I mean this is going to be
so
huge puffer for the field
in assuming I'm able to get this thing
tuned a little bit more
which it's performing very well on the
points that it's sampled like the models
that we have I think are very good and
that is the key is getting those models
correct but then it is it's just the way
that we use the
models internally there two Gan
processes that I've tuned very well to
have quite accurate
predictions that's not the problem the
problem is the scoring function that
tells the Gan process where to sample
based on what it knows at the moment
so one sort of thing um one sort of
Hallmark of a lot of these curves it's
kind of confusing to me
is why they are this
sharp you know this really doesn't look
like a log curve you know like look you
get right here this is
18.7 in 18 seconds right but then you
go just like a little bit low less and
it just falls off
completely I mean even if we assume that
we draw this curve
down this is
still if I think this is much sharper
than a log
right this looks way sharper than a log
to
me it's like almost like a rounded
Corner thing
okay so another good thing would be
score over time do we have score over
time as a
time so very quick you know we're able
to get some good runs
here but then we get all this pollution
down
here this I'm not you know this I'm kind
of okay with some of this up here but
then all this is like sort of
let me go back to looking at that uh
this formula
here cuz I thought I was on something
with the the Min cost it is literally
driving down to Min cost isn't
it yeah look total time steps it's
driving it like straight down to the men
it just doesn't get all the way there by
the end but then cost where's cost
yeah you can see this trend it's driving
it straight into the
ground even over here like by the end
it's doing these like 15sec
runs even though it's not getting
anything out of these runs at
all I mean I could see that it maybe is
trying to fill in this like portion
first so if this sets everything to
INF then this will
which is probably going to be something
pretty low but still
okay this should always be
negative I'm actually I'm kind of
confused because this should it should
literally never be able to do this
and I don't think that we see this in
our synthetic tests either do
see what the latest version is is it
just synthetic test
ion I want to figure out if I can
see I want to figure out why pushes to
low cost if I can figure that out if I
can get that distribution to be
reasonable I think we should be good on
the algorithm I mean obviously like
we're going to run this on a ton of
different things and uh we will
see what that results in but
me pull up a quick web server so we can
check
method
uh
we will see what is wrong with this
thing
I tested this as working so hopefully
there's just some things spre with
it with like a merge or
something it's definitely running the
right out though otherwise it would be
instant
weird this
Behavior the thing is I'm actually like
all these points here I'm kind of fine
with right like putting a bunch of
points on the elbow is totally fine
especially once you've kind of filled
this out because the elbow is this like
really sensitive area where you if you
get an accurate estimate here but you
don't know in practice which of these
points you're going to want the most
like I might decide that this point is
the best for me right here because this
one is like pretty well solved and it's
substantially cheaper than this point
over here or this point over here right
and this elbow can have different shapes
right so like it could be that if you
keep running experiments you find
something over here that's good so I'm
fine with running experiments here and
with any envirment that has a little bit
of variance to it you're going to get
some points over here that don't do as
well um same thing sort of right here
you know it's going for these are ones
that have the potential to fully
solve almost
20.8 but then these ones down here I
don't know what happened like this
should this should not be this populated
at
all you should get very little reward
for stuff that scores this poorly
okay so this is the reference curve here
this is with 110 points though
right so with only 50 or whatever you're
not going to get the full curve
but we can see here that this is
expanding
out so let make sure that this
replicates first so we get something
nice like this and then if we do get
something nice like this we can go from
there also let's just make sure this is
not actually doing the same
thing now you see so we get a couple
points here which is fine just filling
out the curve at the end once it's done
everything else but you can see that
there are still points at the end that
are being placed here filling out this
end of the curve and then quite a few on
the elbow
there's like some stuff
bad we should also probably like make
this
plot for
um we should like add this into the
Neptune or whatever that would be a good
thing to
do so we get it for the real
environments I mean I think we can
pretty much get
this this is the same plot
is only thing is not having the color
scheme
sucks I really wish that you could apply
a color scheme uh to these points
right there's like no option like
there's nothing that you can do to
change this which is
annoying I think I emailed them on this
as well they really should add that it
would really make hyper pram sweeps
better okay so you can see here you're
starting to get full
coverage so I mean for a 50 experiment
run this is like what you would want
right builds up a nice predictive model
it spends some time on this and then it
starts doing these more expensive
okay there you
go not bad at all
right that's like the same curve from
before pretty
well is not going to be one: one exactly
but we do this this is the curve from
before
I think this one has some more points I
might have done all 200 experiments on
this
one I mean this is very well filled in
there only a couple stray points in each
of
these let me see is there cluster over
here no they're like two points that are
relatively NE
recent and then here is there cluster
over
here three points hm
well it did this
one but I can kind of understand these
it's filling in a gap here
right yeah there was a gap and it filled
in a
gap stupid
Bots get out of
then the percent one was terrible
right or is there just something screwy
with
it it'd be really nice to speed up the
um sample speed of this thing
I don't think it uh pyro is particularly
well
optimized this thing should be very
quick to train instant
I'm actually going to watch this run to
see what it's doing because I'm looking
at these ratings on the right hand side
this is how good it thinks each point is
it
sampling okay like you just found this
is a
six this looks like a good point like
why does it only get a rating of 0.6
right
six yeah we definitely need to do some
work just like
on on this so what I think I'll do is
I'm going to it looks like overall maybe
this curve is looking okay
here but
um the ratings are a bit
concerning yeah like look it pushed all
the way out to 25 and 34 47 not getting
anything for
it no score is improving
110 experiments it does fill out the
curve we'll see what it looks like but I
think it'll be
fine and then it'll really be um just a
matter of looking at this SC function to
see if it's doing anything that doesn't
make
sense we can evaluate it on the real
tasks as Al that takes a little
Tas okay there were a few unintuitive
things though even on here that I think
I could look at right so we'll Salvage
going to look for the first like big
cost
jump okay so this one here is predicted
to get a score of 334
334 with a cost of
2.7 and it's only getting about as much
as this one here which has a cost of
1.5 predicted to get
this would be the lowest cost point
though this is the thing so it's going
to get the full score okay fine we'll
we'll look for something more
agous this is still not particularly
egregious
I'm just looking for something where it
looks like I would think it should get a
lot of score and the function doesn't
say it
should now come on give us a cost
jump I think our best score is like 33
33 at this point right
okay so this one should
score pretty darn highly you would think
it does look like it's reasonable
nearby
GP GP YT
reasonable yeah I think that's
reasonable it's going up from
46 so that's like a reasonabl for
difference I would
say and then nearest parito distance
so we have this one but then the nearest
parito point should
be what 2.5 gets 041
oh no wait hold
on rol logy
Norm yeah it's got to be the one
you get kind of linear improvements here
don't
you I think I have two functions that
are fighting each
other
right oh right this one I don't even
use so hang
it's
probably it's probably something like
this that's killing it the log on the
cost this might make it way too
aggressive though
see and so far the score predictions are
not
bad they're underfit if anything thing
so they're
conservative that one's over by a
here that was a decent number of
experiments before it pushed all the way
to the top end of the cost especially
for a simple problem like this I'm
actually this could be better now the
question is how much is it going to hang
out at the top
end so I mean this means that it's going
to linearly
space all the experiments
it is still improving the lower part of
the frontier just
less I think this could be worth trying
on pong at
least we'll see what the graph looks
like
um also would be interesting to see the
compute graphs I
right
oops like it's going to give you a lot
of these points up
here it does still fill in gaps right
it's like still going to go back to fill
in some gaps
I guess we'll have to see what it does
on a real environment to
know to be fair if this one actually
does the opposite and it's too
aggressive then we'll know that it's
somewhere in between that we want
right so maybe we'll do
that yeah let's that would actually be a
good test let's do that we uh we don't
need this extra breakout run
I just want to make sure this isn't
stuck and then I will go get some food
and we will have some
unlucky these are the random trials that
are started that just start the uh
learning
process I'll give it a few minutes just
to make sure we don't end up wasting
time on bad
experiments I didn't think we changed
anything oh with the random search
especially
box a couple more trials before I get
super suspicious you can get bad randoms
to start
what did the random trials look like for
uh for
this I
mean they look better than this didn't
run it's possible I broke something I
don't think so you know this is still
random I think we're fine all right I'm
going to go get some food I will be back
later in the afternoon and uh we will
continue on this and other projects so
thank you if you want to check out my
work on puff. start the GitHub join the
Discord